NEW YORK CITY.
AND THIS IS "THE FIVE" ."
ARE YOU READY FOR WITCH HUNT
2.0?
GET READY, BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT
THE DEMOCRATS ARE GEARING UP
FOR.
AFTER MUELLER'S TESTIMONY FAILED
TO DELIVER THE KNOCKOUT BLOW TO
TRUMP'S PRESIDENCY THAT THEY
PROMISED, NANCY PELOSI AND HER
PALS ARE REVEALING THEIR NEW
PLANS TO GO AFTER
PRESIDENT TRUMP PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> WE ARE FILING AN APPLICATION
FOR THE MATERIAL UNDERLYING THE
MUELLER REPORT.
WE WILL SHAKE TESTIMONY AND KEY
WITNESSES AND TO INVESTIGATE THE
PRESIDENT'S MISCONDUCT.
>> IT WAS CLEAR TO ME YESTERDAY
HE DID NOT FOLLOW THE MONEY.
SO SOMEBODY NEEDS TO DO THE
INVESTIGATION INTO MONEY
LAUNDERING.
WE ARE HAVING A RIGOROUS DEBATE
ABOUT WHETHER WE NEED TO GO ON
INVESTIGATION TO IMPEACHMENT.
>> SIMPLY TRYING TO RUN OUT THE
CLOCK ON THIS?
>> THAT IS NOT TRUE.
I'M NOT TRYING TO RUN OUT THE
CLOCK.
>> Jesse: MOMENTS AGO FROM THE
OVAL OFFICE, PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS
FIRED UP AND SOUNDING OFF ON THE
ENDLESS INVESTIGATIONS.
>> I THINK IT IS A DISGRACE WHAT
THE DEMOCRATS ARE DOING.
ALL THEY WANT TO DO IS IMPEDE.
THEY WANT TO INVESTIGATE.
THEY WANT TO GO FISHING.
AND I WATCH BOB MUELLER.
AND THEY HAVE NOTHING.
IF THESE PEOPLE ARE CLOWNS.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE CLOWNS.
THEY ARE BEING LEFT OUT ALL OVER
THE WORLD.
AND I WATCH THIS MORNING, I
WATCH NANCY PELOSI TRY TO GET
THROUGH THAT WITH THE
PERFORMANCE THAT ROBERT MUELLER
PUT ON WHERE I DON'T THINK HE
EVER READ THE DOCUMENT.
AND IT SAID NO COLLUSION.
THEY DON'T EVEN TALK ABOUT THAT.
SO THERE WAS NO CRIME.
THEY SAID, WELL, THERE WAS NO
CRIME, BUT HE OBSTRUCTED.
HOW DO YOU OBSTRUCT IF THERE IS
NO CRIME?
IT WAS A PHONY CRIME THAT THEY
PUT ON.
THE CRIME WAS WHAT THEY PUT ON.
>> Jesse: CLOWNS, GREG.
>> Greg: YES, CLOWNS.
WHAT ELSE CAN YOU CALL THEM?
YOU LOOK AT THE MEDIA, THEY
EXPECTED, LET'S MAKE A DEAL.
THEY EXPECTED A SHINY CORVETTE
BEHIND DOOR NUMBER ONE.
WHEN THE CURTAIN PULLED BACK IT
WAS AN INFLATABLE DOLL.
NOTHING THERE FOR THEM.
AND THEN THEY ARE SAYING SOME OF
THE MEDIA IS SAYING IT IS A
MIXED BAG.
YES, A MIXED BAG OF DOG, CAT,
AND HORSE.
THEY CAN'T TAKE THE L, WHAT THIS
WAS A GREAT WEEK FOUR WAS NORMAL
PEOPLE, MEANING PEOPLE NOT PRONE
TO HYSTERICS OR EMOTIONAL
VENDETTAS.
YOU CAN WATCH THIS WITH A
DETACHED OBSERVER.
THIS COULD GO ONE WAY OR THE
OTHER.
BUT YOUR WHOLE LIFE IS NOT
HANGING ON AT THE WAY THAT IT
DOES WITH MORNING JOE.
AS IF THEY ARE HAVING PUBLIC
NERVOUS BREAKDOWNS OVER THIS.
IF THEY WENT THE OTHER WAY, WE
WOULD GET ON WITH HER LIFE.
WE WOULD HAVE DINNER, FEEL BAD
ONE WAY OR ANOTHER BECAUSE WE
SUPPORT THE PRESIDENT.
WE DON'T WANT THEIR HYSTERIA TO
BE PROVEN TRUE.
BUT NOW YOU SEE THE DEMOCRATS IN
BUT NOW YOU SEE THE DEMOCRATS II
THE MEDIA REDOUBLING THEIR
EFFORTS AFTER THIS FAILURE,
REDOUBLING THE EFFORTS FOR
IMPEACHMENT.
BUT IMAGINE IF WE ARE HEARING
WHAT WAS GOOD FOR THEM, WHAT
WOULD THEY HAVE DONE?
IF IT IS BAD FOR THEM, WHAT ARE
THEY DOING?
THEY WOULD HAVE HAD TORCHES AND
TAR AND FEATHERS.
>> Jesse: IT WOULD'VE BEEN
PITCHFORKS AT 1600, DAN.
THEY TRIED TO FRAME HIM AND
INVESTIGATE THEM, THEY FAILED.
WHAT ELSE CAN THEY DO?
>> Dan: GUYS, LADIES, HAVE
SOME DIGNITY.
ISN'T THIS EMBARRASSING?
GREG, THEY ARE THROWING STUFF AT
THE WALL RIGHT NOW.
FIRST IT WAS COLLUSION, THAN IT
WAS A HOAX, THAN IT WAS MONEY
LAUNDERING.
NEXT IT WILL BE FELONIOUS
MOWBRAY.
PIRACY ON THE OPEN SEA.
JAYWALKING AFTER -- AGGRAVATED
JAYWALKING.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT IT IN THE
GREEN ROOM, DON'T DO IT.
I SAID TO GREG, CAN YOU TAKE THE
L?
YOU LOST.
NOBODY HAS TO READ MY LIPS,
EVERY REPUBLICAN SEES IT, BIG
LOSS, SHOULD NOT HAVE READ MY
LIPS, THE DEMOCRATS, LISTEN, I
AM GIVING YOU FREE POLITICAL
ADVICE, I KNOW WHAT IT IS LIKE.
I LOST WHEN I RAN FOR OFFICE.
TO TAKE THE L, THE CASE IS OVER.
HE IS RIGHT.
>> Greg: I DON'T THINK YOU
SHOULD HAVE ACCEPTED THE LOSS.
>> Dan: THIS IS FOR A REASON.
>> Capri: HANGING CHAD'S AND
DIMPLED CHADS, I WILL CHIME IN
ON GETTING FREE POLITICAL ADVICE
AS A DEMOCRAT AT THE TABLE ON
FRIDAY AFTERNOON.
I HAVE BEEN SAYING THIS UNTIL I
AM BLUE IN THE FACE.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE
INVESTIGATION FATIGUE AND WHEN
THEY GO DOWN THIS PATH WHERE
THEY WILL NOT GIVE UP AND THEY
ARE FOCUSED MORE ON TRYING TO
GET AT THE PRESIDENT AND ON
IMPORTANT POLICY ISSUES THAT
WILL HELP THEM WIN THE MIDTERM
ELECTIONS, WE SET OURSELVES UP
TO BE THE GREATEST ADVERSARY FOR
TRUMP, BECAUSE WE ARE PLAYING
INTO HIS HAND.
WE ARE SAYING WE ALL HAVE TRUMP
DERANGEMENT SYNDROME AND HE WILL
SAY, C, C, C.
THAT DISTRACTS.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY THERE ARE SOME
DEMOCRATS THAT HAVE NOT GOTTEN
THE MEMO, IF THEY DON'T GET IT
SOON, THE CLOCK IS TICKING AND
WE WILL BE IN NOT A GREAT
POSITION TO TAKE ON TRUMP IN
JUST A FEW MONTHS.
>> Jesse: THERE ARE SO MANY
COMMITTEES IN THE HOUSE, THIS
WAS JUST ONE OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE, INTEL COMMITTEE.
AND THAT'S ALL THE MEDIA IS
FOCUSED ON AND DEMOCRATS ARE
FOCUSED ON.
THEY CAN'T WALK AND CHEW GUM AT
THE SAME TIME.
THEY CAN'T DO INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
HEALTH CARE, ASYLUM, CAN'T DO
ANYTHING EXCEPT FOR THIS.
>> Dagen: THE PROBLEM IS THAT
THEY ONLY TALK AND LISTEN TO
PEOPLE WHO WEAR MAKE UP FOR A
LIVING, NO OFFENSE, JESSE.
>> Jesse: IT'S ONLY A LITTLE
BLUSH.
>> Dagen: BUT HE IS TALKING
ABOUT REGULAR FOLKS.
AND THAT IS ONE THING THAT THE
DEMOCRATS AND PEOPLE ON OTHER
NETWORKS DON'T UNDERSTAND IS HIS
ABILITY TO TALK TO REGULAR FOLKS
IN THE COUNTRY.
AND WE ARE MAD AND HE IS RANTING
AND RAVING, BUT YOU KNOW WHAT,
PEOPLE AT HOME WOULD BE TOO.
I WOULD HOLD A GRUDGE IF
SOMEBODY WED AFTER ME AND TRIED
TO DESTROY ME.
I WOULD BE CHAFED, CHAPPED, AND
WHITE-HOT MAD ABOUT IT.
THEN FOLLOWED BY ALL THIS NOT
NOSED BRATS WHO HAVE HATED TRUMP
HIS WHOLE LIFE AND ALWAYS WANTED
TO TAKE HIM DOWN.
I WOULD BE AS FURIOUS AS HE IS.
AND THIS FEROCITY HAS WORKED FOR
HIM.
THE PERCENTAGE OF PEOPLE WHO
OPPOSE IMPEACHMENT HAS CONTINUED
TO GO UP.
ALMOST TWO-THIRDS OF PEOPLE IN
THE SURVEY.
AND THE PERCENTAGE IN FAVOR HAS
GONE DOWN.
SO AGAIN --
>> Capri: NANCY PELOSI IS
TRYING TO SLOW WALK IT NO MATTER
WHAT.
>> Jesse: I WONDER WHAT IT
WOULD BE LIKE IF HE DID NOT HAVE
THE TWO-YEAR INVESTIGATION
HOLDING OVER HIS HEAD, BECAUSE
HE HAD A POLL COME OUT IN
"THE WASHINGTON POST" AT 47%.
THAT IS AN ALL-TIME HIGH IN THAT
POLL BEFORE THE MUELLER HEARING.
AND THE FOX NEWS POLL THAT HAD
THE APPROVAL FOR THE ECONOMY AT
DECADE HIGH.
THIS IS PRETTY GOOD STUFF RIGHT
NOW.
AND NOW WE WILL COME INTO A
RECESS WHERE EVERYBODY GOES
HOME.
I THINK HE WILL LOOK EVEN
BETTER.
>> Dan: THIS WAS A HEAVY
ANCHOR AROUND HIS NECK.
WHAT IS IRONIC ABOUT THIS IS
BOOMERANG ON THE DEMOCRATS, AND
THEY HAVE NO CAPACITY FOR SELF
REFLECTION.
I THINK IT WAS DAVID GERGEN ON
THE OTHER NETWORKS, NOBODY
WATCHES OUTSIDE OF THE AIRPORT,
HE SAID SOMETHING, PASSIVELY
WATCHING, HE SAID, LISTEN.
WE ARE NOT REALLY OPEN TO THE
REPUBLICANS ARGUMENT HERE.
AND THEY HAVE BEEN STUDYING THE
CASE FOR A LONG TIME.
THAT'S WHY WE ARE UNPREPARED.
AND EVERYBODY OVER THERE AT THE
AIRPORT WAS SHOCKED.
MAYBE HE IS RIGHT?
WE HAVE TO WITHSTAND THE ATTACKS
ABOUT THE HOAX, PEOPLE AT THE
TABLE HAVE DONE THE HOMEWORK.
HAS YOU LOOK INTO IT IT IS ALL
ABOUT THE DEMOCRATS AND RUSSIA.
>> Jesse: THAT WAS THE FIRST
TIME IN THE COUNTRY, OUTSIDE OF
FOX NEWS MAY BE HEARD THE NAME
MENTIONED, FUSION GPS, GLENN
SIMPSON'S NAME.
THE DOSSIER.
THEY NEVER HEARD THAT.
AND I DON'T THINK IT HAS BEEN
COVERED BY THE FOREIGN NEWS
NETWORKS.
>> Greg: IT IS MORE BRITISH
COLLUSION THEN RUSSIAN, AND TO
THE CREDIBILITY OF THE ENDEAVOR
IS GONE.
SO MAYBE IT IS A PULITZER TO
INVESTIGATE THE INVESTIGATION.
BECAUSE HOW DID THIS MOVE
FORWARD?
HOW DO PEOPLE NOT SEE THIS
COMING?
OR DID THEY KNOW THAT MUELLER
WAS NOT ENGAGED IN THE
INVESTIGATION AND WERE HAPPY
THAT HE WAS NOT ENGAGED, BECAUSE
THEY WERE DOING OTHER THINGS.
THAT WOULD MAKE A GREAT STORY
FOR A NETWORK.
>> Jesse: THAT IS THE POINT,
BECAUSE HE SAID HE HAD NO IDEA
WHAT WAS GOING ON IN THE
INVESTIGATION AND IT WAS RUN BY
CLINTON DONORS AND CLINTON
LAWYERS.
YOU HAVE TO THINK THAT HE IS
BEING INVESTIGATED BY HIS
POLITICAL OPPONENT.
THIS IS NOT THE NONPARTISAN
INVESTIGATION THAT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE WERE TOLD THAT IT WAS.
>> Dagen: THIS IS THE RISK
THAT DEMOCRATS TOOK WHEN THEY
DECIDED TO GO DOWN THE ROAD TO
PUT ALL OF THE EGGS IN THIS
BASKET AND CALL MUELLER TO
TESTIFY IN FRONT OF THE
COMMITTEES.
BECAUSE 1 OF 2 THINGS WOULD
HAPPEN.
IF HE DID NOT EXPLICITLY SAY,
YES, I WOULD HAVE CHARGED HIM
WITH A CRIME WHICH WAS WHAT THEY
DID NOT SAY.
YOU KNOW, THEY ARE GOING TO
LOSE.
AND SO WHEN IT COMES OUT THAT
MUELLER WAS NOT AS ENGAGED IN
THIS PROCESS WHEN HE DID NOT
ANSWER SO MANY OTHER QUESTIONS
I'M NOT GOING TO GET INTO THIS.
IT REALLY HURT THE DEMOCRATS FOR
PUTTING ALL OF THE EGGS IN THE
BASKET.
>> Dagen: YOU KNOW WHO NEVER
WOULD'VE CALLED BOB MUELLER TO
TESTIFY?
DONALD TRUMP, HE WOULD HAVE DONE
RESEARCH TO FIND OUT THAT THE
GUY SHOULD NOT BE SITTING IN
FRONT OF THE PUBLIC.
BUT THE DEMOCRATS ALL TALK TO
THEMSELVES AND GO, YEAH, YOU ARE
DOING A GREAT JOB.
THIS IS GOING TO BE A WIN.